este miércoles ucrania ganó a escocia en
glasgow en los playoffs de europa para
la copa mundo era un partido que estaba
previsto para disputarse en marzo y que
se aplazó tras la invasión rusa los
ucranianos ganaron por 3 a 1 en el que
fue el primer encuentro de competición
de ucrania desde el inicio de la guerra
no hay liga en su país y la mayoría de
los jugadores tuvieron que concentrarse
en eslovenia
[Aplausos]
y así se celebró en este bar de quienes
gritos de alegría para estos aficionados
que pasaron la noche en este reciento en
medio del toque de queda si ucrania gana
el domingo a gales en la final de los
playoff irán al mundial según su
entrenador ellos hacen esto por su gente
sus casas y jugamos por ellos jugamos
por aquellos que pelean en las
trincheras
los que combaten hasta su última gota de
sangre también jugamos por los
ucranianos que están en casa los que
sufren cada día